isn't everything we're doing in life way
to be loved a little more hi there I'm
Aria and I'm looking for my soulmate I
began my search a few months ago and
although that story ultimately didn't
have a happy ending I now find myself in
Vienna the setting for one of my
favorite films of all time in before
sunrise to strangers spend one
incredible night wandering the city
together before going their separate
ways
and since I'm leaving Vienna tomorrow
morning I figure what better way to
spend my final night here that by trying
to recreate that magic with a stranger I
could ask you a quick question yeah of
course
so this is my last night in Vienna and
I'm looking for someone to explore it
with me for the evening because Google
fits us well we're going to birthday
party no no I rejected left and right
c'est difficile may be possible to be
harder than I thought how confident you
feel in Shoshana scale of 1 to 10
I don't know if you know em cool it's
like Museumsquartier there's a lot of
young people I would love to but I
cannot see for sure
I could be going better better I'm
optimistic let's go to the monster yeah
this is good I get rejected a lot
tonight and built up my tolerance so
sorry to bother you I could ask you a
quick question
my name is Aria what's your name nice to
meet you this is gonna sound crazy okay
it's my last night in Vienna I leave
tomorrow morning and we're looking to
find someone to come explore the city
with me tonight and I'm wondering if you
would be able to join us sure she says
sure she says sure really for sure I
don't know if we should I cheer this is
my first time in in Vienna I say yeah we
need to come here I arrived two days ago
today two days ago I feel like it's a
first I love it I live in LA when were
you in their life yeah it's like some
years ago but it was like I was there
for like exchange from Adelaide
all right no no just go to change
Wisconsin
what it was Scott Wow so you're from
Vienna born and raised yeah Wow so you
must have something beyond a fun fact to
show I don't know it's I know it's just
it's so different if you like raise and
live here and it's like you don't mean I
don't really have too much of a face and
you know but you love the city yes tim
is offbeat Anglosphere because the
beautiful yeah well this beer what's the
closest beer big beer oh my said what's
it like Bon Appetit
what am i eating catfish bits okay so
what is tafelspitz it's me first course
I have to warn you though if I keep
drinking this this videos gonna go
places
[Music]
and so what is snaps though well first
just like try it and then I'll explain
maybe I don't like that I'm so sorry
okay I try to be respectful all cultures
how was that for you thank you
[Music]
Gus is not good I'm so sorry
dismissed good I think the worst part
about it is is too strong it's like 80
proof but 83 are you yeah when I first
taught my team about this video I said
oh it's gonna be this beautiful piece
about you know two people connecting
less than one hour after meeting you I'm
gagging on some so steps there's
different kinds of connections no this
is absolutely not like what happened it
before sunrise just before sunrise -
before I pass my odds let's hear your
honest you want say hi to your aunt
actually think she's sleeping right now
of the kids day it's kind of late yeah
it's true it's almost midnight and here
we are wandering the streets what I'm
gonna miss about Europe this is how I
everything's still walkable because in
the u.s. we don't walk anywhere I know I
still sad like I really I I missed it
when I was there when you were last oh
yeah Wisconsin would you like this out
of music actually is not like it's thing
that I send it
what oh my god sorry
so what do you know about st. Stephen's
Cathedral oh you tell me first and I'm
going to tell you st. Stephen's
Cathedral very old cathedral but
apparently it houses in a crypt the
organs of hofburg family Royals as well
as the dead skeletons of people who died
in the plague very romantic
I think it's can actually it's bad that
st. Stephen's Cathedral isn't really
that important at the newsperson
you just walk by and you don't really
realize how important it is because if
you live here you just don't really
think about those things too much time
let's me know how crazy did you think I
was well at first I was like oh my god I
feel so sorry because it's raining and
you were so excited about this and I was
just so tired I was like oh my god I
can't do this but you know you're so
nice I was like I have to do this now
but then it turned out so wait but I
really enjoyed the evening it was so now
yeah I think I think it's a lot a really
great time
you know I believe if that's any kind of
God
it wouldn't be in any of us not you or
me but just this little space in between
if there's any kind of magic in this
world it must be in the attempt of
understanding someone sharing something
I know it's almost impossible to succeed
but yes really the answer must be in the
attempt sad I just met you but
everything has to end but the boy I
think yeah you come to LA we come to
anything do you like me
oh come thank them I think it worked out
the way it was meant to work out I think
it something very bittersweet and the
idea that I spent one great night with a
great girl who I hope maybe never see
again but that's what life is about
right it's about making memories
[Music]
yeah it's about making memories
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part